good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how to race
yourself our struggle over the you
lecrae I would tell myself man to brace
yourself for real struggle for real pain
for death for loss for you know hurt and
then as an artist I would I would tell
myself you know what I what I say and I
put on the back of the book - if you
live for people's acceptance you'll die
from their rejection and that's what I
would tell people because tell myself is
I was so worried about being accepted
these people to accept me these people
to accept me and when they don't you die
you crumble inside you devastated but if
you already know who you are like I feel
like I'm made in God's image my Worth
and value cannot be tainted you know you
can't add to my work you can't take away
from it I was born with it and so I
don't have to fight for your approval
your acceptance and I want my younger
self to know that be confident in who
God made me to be and be the best me I
could be so starting a business is one
of the hardest things you will ever do
in your life people think it's going to
be easy but it's one of the hardest
things you will ever do in your life no
matter how hard you think it's going to
be no matter how many videos you watch
it people telling you it's difficult
it's still way harder and way worse than
what you thought it was going to be it
just is that's life as an entrepreneur
people will judge you people will
criticize you people will hate on you
you're one of the cash faster than you
thought you would customers aren't going
to come through the door like you
thought they would the media is not
going to cover you like you thought they
would your social media campaigns are
going to take off like you thought you
would basically if you take whatever
idea you had and you have a best-case
realistic case worst-case scenario it's
always way worse than your worst case
scenario that's just life as an
entrepreneur and I want to be realistic
and share that because I really
struggled at the beginning and I wasn't
prepared for it i read magazine articles
and you know I saw documentaries of
people who had success as an
entrepreneur I thought I can do this I
can be an entrepreneur too and I was
prepared to do the work I didn't think
it would just be handed to me but I
wasn't prepared for how low I would feel
about myself when I was making a $300 a
month and I was working and working and
working and not getting any results and
not getting any callbacks not getting
any people buying them seeing so little
traction that I felt at that point the
lowest I've ever felt in my life
because I knew that anything else that I
worked on I could get some results with
at school or athletics whatever I worked
on it would improve and here I was
working and I wasn't getting any results
and I just felt so low I felt worthless
I felt like I had no value and I
actually told my business partner that I
quit
at what point because I just felt like I
needed to do something where I could
feel like I'm contributing something
because this just sucked and I was too
embarrassed and too ashamed to tell
other people about it you know my
friends would ask him to come out to
birthday parties or beer night or
anything like that and I could I always
had to say no because I couldn't afford
it I could you know $20 was too
expensive for me and I had to pick one
thing a month that I could go to but I
would never tell my friends what was
happening I would always say that I'm
living the entrepreneur lifestyle you
know I'm just hustling hard on my
business I was too embarrassed to let
them know what the truth was and so I
think part of what I wanted to share in
this channel is showing the struggles
that people go through to make it that
it often doesn't happen in the first
year or two years or three years we have
to have a deep passion for what you're
doing and just keep doing it and keep
doing it and keep doing it and you do it
because you enjoy the work because
making YouTube videos is fun for me I
enjoy be able to reach you guys whether
I end up hitting my million subscriber
goal or other big goals that I have or
not I enjoy doing the work and so I
think if you really have a deep passion
for what you're doing and expect to
struggle then you let yourself off the
hook a little bit just from an emotional
point of view that when you don't hit
the results immediately
you don't beat yourself up and feel
worthless about it and you use that as
motivation to go off and do better
so the question day today is I'm curious
what was the biggest surprise that you
had as an entrepreneur something that
you weren't expecting
but then that happened to you that you
had to deal with and struggle through
really curious to find out share your
story in the comments below I also want
to give a quick shout out to Kelvin
spoon Kelvin thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me man
and I hope you're enjoying the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events
if the depth of anybody struggle will
determine the height of their success
and I believe that everything that I've
gone through in my whole life you know
people ask me what would you change I
wouldn't change a thing because
everything that I've gone through is
made me who I am today you know so I'm
feel very strong and very complicated
you know and it got a lot of love for a
lot a lot of people you know Jesus
struggled and went through things you
know everybody went through the old day
and uh and people slanted him I mean I
feel like if Jesus could go what he went
through
Who am I I'm nobody
because that's a guy from the lulav
Anja's that just do this music you know
but I was just such a real person I
don't consider myself a celebrity at all
I'm just so real and I love people that
you know man I just flow through this
thing you know and I let my music I'm
like God Gaby what he got me to go but
God ain't gonna just guide you straight
to success not God he gonna guide you
through a lot of mess first so that when
you get the success you know how to
appreciate it you know how to stay with
it and know how to take care of it not
that and that's called longevity biggest
challenge of this year actually was
convincing members of my own team that
this was a good call I'd get kind of
called in front of a group of people who
have known me and worked with me for
years who would sit down at that are you
sure you want to call the album 1989 we
think it's a weird title are you sure
that you want to put an album cover out
that has less than half of your face on
it
are you positive that you want to you
want to take a genre that you have that
cemented yourself in and completely
switch to a new one that you are a
newcomer to and answering all those
questions with yes I'm sure that was I
think something that really frustrated
me at the time like guys don't you
understand
I promise this is this is what I'm dying
to do the biggest kind of struggle
turned into the biggest triumph when it
worked out when I was seven and a half I
was raped
I won't say severely rate don't rate
this severe the rapist was a person very
well-known to my family I was
hospitalized the rapist was let out of
jail and was found dead that night and
the police suggested that the rapist had
been kicked to death I was seven and a
half I thought that I had caused the
man's death because I had spoken his
name that was my seven and a half year
old logic so I stopped talking for five
years now to show you again how out of
evil there can come good in those five
years I read every book in the black
school library I read all the books I
could get from the white school library
I memorized James Weldon Johnson Paul
Laurence Dunbar Countee Cullen and
Langston Hughes's I memorized
Shakespeare whole plays fifty sarnax
I memorized Edgar Allan Poe all the
poetry never having heard it I memorized
I had known solo I had Gita mocha song I
had balls I'd Rudyard Kipling I mean it
was the Catholic kind of reading and
Catholic kind of story when I decided to
speak
I had a lot to say and many ways in
which to say what I had to say I listen
to the black minister and listen to the
melody of the preachers and I could tell
when they would start up from that kind
of thing when we know they mean to take
our soul straight to heaven or whether
they meant to - us straight to hell I
understood it - out of this
Iza which was a dire kind of evil
because rape on the body of a young
person more often than not introduces
cynicism and there is nothing quite so
tragic as a young cynic because it means
the person has gone from knowing nothing
to believing nothing in my case I was
saved in that mutinous sea in the sort
of that I was saved and I was able to
draw from human thought human
disappointments and triumph enough to
transfer myself